[موسيقى]
وصول وزير الخارجيه الايراني الى الرياض
اليوم اعتقد انه بناء على برنامج زمني وضع
سلفا في اعاده العلاقه في المتعلق
بالاتفاقيه السعوديه الايرانيه الموقعه في
10 مارس وكذلك
التزاما من الطرفين في هذه الاتفاقيه هي
نتيجه لوصول الاطراف السعوديه والايرانيه
الى قناعه كبيره في مساله تحقيق ما اتفق
عليه سلفا انا اتصور ان البلدين لهما
اراده سياسيه كامله
لاستئناف العلاقات لتجاوز المشاكل التي
حصلت في الماضي ولاقامه علاقات تعاون
وتكامل بين البلدين من دون شك
تحسين العلاقات بين ايران والسعوديه وايضا
مع الدول الاخرى سيترك اثاره على
مجمل العلاقات الاقليميه لكن علينا ان
نعرف جيدا ان البلدين يهتمان في هذه
الفتره لاستئنافي العلاقات الدبلوماسيه زر
الخارجيه الايراني اليوم تحدث عن منظومه
الامن الاقليمي ويقصد بالتحديد منظومه
الامن في الخليج الفارسي واراد ان يؤكد
ضروره ان تكون منظومه الامن منظومه ذاتيه
اتفاقات حصلت بين المملكه وايران وكانت
واضحه وقع عليها الطرفان تشمل قضايا
المنطقه المختلف عليها والصراعات
الهيدروجيه التي تشكو منها السعوديه
والدول العربيه في المنطقه والزام ايران
في احد البنود الاتفاقيه بعدم التدخل في
الشان العربي الحقيقه الاتفاق الايراني
السعودي لم يتطرق الى هذه الملفات المملكه
العربيه السعوديه خلال مفاوضاتها مع
الجانب الايراني في فتره مكان حينما كانت
هذه المفاوضات في العراق او بعد ذلك في
عمان كانت تصير على
وضع حل للازمه الجاريه في اليمن وايران
كان موقفها دائما موضوع اليمن وموضوع يمني
يمني ويمني سعودي ولا علاقه للجمهوريه
الاسلاميه
الايرانيه في كل ذلك
على الاتفاقيه الا بعد وضوح كل شيء اولاها
يعني
تخفيض التصعيد في المنطقه سواء على مستوى
الحشد الشعبي في العراق او اليمن او لبنان
او حتى سوريا لذلك الاتفاقيه السعوديه
الايرانيه هي الان تمشي يعني توازنا مع ما
اتفق فيه تنفيذيا
اي تقدم في تحسين العلاقات الثنائيه
والاقليميه يؤدي ويؤثر على مختلف القضايا
العالقه بين هذه بين الطرفين او بين
الاطراف في المنطقه الجانب السعودي اكد
على
النقطه الامنيه الجانب الايراني ايضا اكد
على العلاقات السياسيه كلاهما اكد على
تنفيذ الاتفاقيات السابقه هناك اتفاقيه
امنيه مشتركه هناك اتفاقيه تعاون اقتصادي
مواضيع هذه الاتفاقيات واضحه لدى الجميع
اي المراقب يقرا الاتفاقيه او التصريح
ممكن يقراها قراءه صحيحه او يقراها على
هواه لكن وزير الخارجيه السعوديه عندما
قال اليوم تعزيز الثقه المتبادله الثقل
متبادله تعني اشياء كثيره بين المملكه
وايران وايضا تعزيز الاستق الاقليمي يعني
الامن في البحرين وفي اليمن وفي الكويت
وفي مجلس التعاون الخليجي وايضا يشمل
العراق استئناف البعثات الدبلوماسيه
استدلبها الوزير الخارجيه السعودي على
تقدم وتطور العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه
ايران والسعوديه دولتان كبيرتان في
المنطقه وانا اتصور ان كلاهما يتحمل
مسؤوليه دعم القضايا العادله ودعم شعوب
المنطقه في قضيه فلسطين في القضايا الاخرى
في المنطقه في مكافحه الارهاب لابد ان
تحظى شعوب المنطقه بدعم كلا الدولتين يعني
اتفاق ضروري للسعوديه مع ايران اللي هو
الاتفاق البترولي اذا لم يكن هناك يعني
اتفاق سعودي ايراني وتنسيق على اعلى مستوى
اعتقد في اسعار البترول ومساله اوبك لن
يكون هناك نجاح
لدول في مساله تقرير اسعار البترول
المستقبلا
[موسيقى]
اي اراده تاتي من الخارج ان كان ذلك في
امن منطقه الخليج الفارسي تواجد القوات
الاجنبيه في هذه المنطقه التاثير من قبل
الاداره الامريكيه التوقعات بالنسبه
للانتخابات القادمه في الولايات المتحده
ربما تاثيرات اقليميه او المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تسعى عن مصالحها سواء مصالح
الامنيه او الاقتصاديه لذلك ساعد الى
توقيع هذا الاتفاق مع ايران بالضمانات
الصينيه حتى يعني تضمن
امن بلادها وامن المنطقه منطقه الشرق
الاوسط للسعوديه خارجه عن اي ضغوط سواء
امريكيه اوروبيه او اي من ايا كان